steve blue showing up today to honor and
support police officers who are under
siege in america right now across the
country cops are being gunned down every
single day
six law enforcement officers were shot
in less than 48 hours and today in new
york the nypd honoring fallen officer
jason rivera who was murdered execution
style along with his partner after they
were ambushed by a felon with a massive
rap sheet
the city's new police commissioner
saying it's time to respect police again
and push back against the anarchy that's
being unleashed
we may not match the sacrifice made by
jason
but we can try to match his incredible
sense of service
we may not match his courage but we can
try to match his passion
the horror that took their lives is an
affront to every decent caring human
being in this city and beyond
those who seek to dim the beacons of
hope across these five boroughs look
outside
hear our voices
see the presence in this cathedral
the nypd will never give up this city
and the widow of officer rivera not
holding back and calling out radical
district attorneys who are putting cops
and the people they protect at risk
the system continues to fail us
we are not safe anymore
not even the members of the service
i know you were tired of these laws
especially the ones from the new d.a
today was a turning point in the city
judge
i'm sure you felt that i felt that the
people of the city felt that and it's
about damn time
and i believe we are going to go forward
from here do you believe that your lips
to god's ears first of all let me say
that the speeches were powerful in saint
patrick's
when the widow of jason rivera got up
and talked about her husband being tired
of the news laws especially of uh the
new d.a she got a standing ovation by
the priest by the cardinal everyone gave
her a standing ovation here's the
problem we
the the the public have been silent it's
this this minority that is just so loud
that they are they are literally
silencing the rest of us who are just
kind of going along with our lives
here's the bottom line it's criminal
privilege right now there is a war on
capture absolutely right but it's time
to end it and the way to end it is with
governors who talk out of both sides of
their mouths governor hochul was at this
funeral today she says on the one hand
i'm not going to change the bail law so
we're going to keep letting the
criminals out but i'm going to work with
mayor adams she's got to go she takes
one side or the other alvin bragg
whoever the new governor is hopefully
will put him out of office he does not
deserve to be in office but we've got to
fine-tune it to the individuals the
judge there's a particular judge dennis
boyle who continuously lets out these
young people with gun crimes over and
over three times let a young kid out on
different guns and then finally he ends
up shooting a cop
these are judges who have the power but
don't use it it's time to fine tune it
because we're all going to lose we can't
survive in our society with this chaos
and it is a turning point because we
stand strong and i've stood in many of
those lines we are strong we are united
that blue line isn't thin it's a lot
thicker than you think greg gutfeld your
thoughts on today
well i mean those pictures were amazing
and it just it it i do agree that i
think it's a turning point
but it shouldn't be if you're surprised
by this you're an idiot because you know
we're in this memory erasing industry
where one story knocks out another story
like you're playing a game of pool uh
but you have to remember how we got here
there was
almost a two-year demoralization of
police you know championed by the media
and by the activists right uh married to
progressive policies in an ideology that
we're in an oppressive society and
therefore we everything has to change a
year ago if you turned on cnn or msnbc
they would portray the police as
basically ms-13 with better uniforms
they were demonized so now you turn you
flip around the channels today and you
see on cnn and other places they're
covering the f the funerals right uh
because now cops are getting shot and
left and right and many some of them are
dying and so they realize that they
created the atmosphere for random
violence by by basically negating the
the authority of the police and so now
they cover the funeral
because they sense the tide is turning
and they're caught in the undertow and
they do deserve to drown metaphorically
speaking the media hates covering crime
because if it does not personally
involve them why does it matter and then
it does their own beliefs open the door
to progressive disasters like the no
bail no cash bail and you don't need
context to cover crime you only need two
variables victim and victimizer media
hates that because that's too easy they
need to have context which means root
causes and systemic racism and he was a
abandoned as a child and so suddenly the
criminal is decriminalized and the
victim is forgotten politics becomes the
end game that's where we're at and you
know we talked we already covered cnn
basically saying that the our coverage
of crime was an instagram filter i hope
they sent brian stelter to the funerals
and took pictures of the mourners and
used the correct instagram filter when
they did it and maybe they'd get some
good retweets out of it so jillian
you're uh washington-based is that true
are you feeling what is going on up here
in new york is this this a new york
centric thing or
it's a national situation right yeah
carjackings in the last year in d.c have
reached record highs it's looking so far
like at the beginning of 2022 that trend
is continuing upwards i will tell you
that on thursday
five people were shot at a hotel one of
them fatally in washington d.c so crime
violent crime is a major problem there
as well to today's event i will say that
jason rivera's widow was correct when
she said that the system failed him
because in a very poignant sense his
death is not
only the responsibility of his killer by
which i mean at least
a small part of the blame here goes to
the city and to its leadership i'm
someone who usually looks to policy
solutions for the nation's biggest
problems but fixing the policy here is
only a small part of the solution you
know decriminalizing violent crime is a
real part of the problem but you're not
going to fix this until you get at the
anti-police sentiment that is running
rampant across the country i don't know
how you do that but it takes all of us
meaning all everybody in america all of
us americans standing together to try
and combat it i think it's it's a tall
order but i think that's where the focus
should go now when you talk about moving
forward we all need to get involved we
should be more explicit when we talk
about the system
you mentioned the name of the judge we
know bragg in the district attorney's
office we know who the governor is we
know the speaker of the house or the
majority leader in the state legislature
they write these bail laws and they
don't reform them we know who the people
are this has to be personalized right
for the message to get through
absolutely i look at there's nothing
more than to echo my my heart goes out
to the moore family and rivera family uh
i do think it's a turning point
your honor and from this standpoint and
everybody's comments around the table
this widow's comments and her words and
the energy and passion that she that she
showed is going to be shown all across
this state to your point to your point
jesse those who are willing to fund
efforts to change communities there
ought to be an effort funded right now
let her words be the only words in the
commercial to recall any d.a that does
not
implement tough laws
any legislature does not that does not
reform bell reform and let that be let
those be the words to help energize
re-energize and rekindle to gil scott
herron's comments about how we support
police officers i think every community
in this city black white hispanic asian
all want to support and all do support
police officers that that widow's
comments
should not only help do that but you may
get a little upset with me now two gun
the gun that killed those two officers
was a ghost gun from philadelphia we
ought to figure out ways to enact smart
gun laws not only do we need bell reform
not only do we need weight
need activists who want to reform police
police departments we have to support
our cops first before we can do any of
this and i hope those words today
resonate not only with
d.a bragg and the chief of police and
the mayor of this town but every d.a in
this country and more importantly for
those of us who want bail reform every
legislature in albany legislature in
albany i'd have to listen to what this
widow said today no would no woman
should ever have to say those things no
wife or mom should ever have to say
those things but she did and we should
try our hardest to limit that from ever
happening again all right here here hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else